all right i got another video for you
guys um somebody asked me how to do all
those keys this is going to show how to
do it on the um all those keys on like
an mdx the new mdxs
and the tlx's
rlx's it's all going to be the same
process on all the models this is how
it's going to go um basically what i'm
going to do is these are the remotes
that came with the car i'm going to be
adding this as a third because i'm going
to be adding the uh
the touch screen remote for the car
that's going to be in another video
but for now i'm going to program this
one in
with these two even though i have these
keys i'm going to move them far away
from the car so the car won't boot on
and i'm going to show you guys how to
you know register
keys that uh aren't registered to the
vehicle
because all you when you lose all the
keys the process
okay
so right now i'm just going to keep this
that's the emergency key to get in and
out the vehicle don't really need it
right now but
so i'm just going to take this and put
this to the side
okay
and then show you guys the ignition
turns on
because i have the key in the vicinity
so i'm going to take the keys out of the
vicinity
and uh
and then we're going to catch back the
video
okay so now i'm back in the vehicle i
have no keys
you see when i hit the button
it doesn't power on
so now i'm going to do all those keys
process here
and show you guys how it's done
so
acura
this same process will work on all
hondas
like the new year hondas also
because it's the same system
so we're gonna go to manual selection
[Music]
this is the mdx smart key
push to start
let me go to hot functions
i'm going to say no
so now it's going to force start the car
on
i'm going to hold down the button
and the vehicle 4 started
it 4 started the vehicle on
so we can start the process
of programming in a new key
so right now it's showing no keys see
the key light blinking here
the agreed key light means that it's
it's blinking meaning that there's no
key uh
on the vehicle
so now it's configuring the system
this might take a little while it takes
like a minute or two so once that minute
of two is up then i'll catch back the
video oh here we go okay so then we have
all those keys guided so we're gonna go
to all those keys
and press start
okay so it says get one keyless access
remote so that's what i'm gonna do i'm
gonna get one keyless access remote and
i'm gonna come right back into the
vehicle
all right so i have one keyless access
remote
in the car
okay
try to sit it
right here
okay
it says turn the ignition on
this is all else keys process
i'm just letting just showing you guys
the video
please take one keyless asset from row
into the vehicle
and remove all others press ok
it's ignition turned on by pressing the
start button twice
[Music]
yes it does
it's going through the system just
checking everything
would you like to learn the next key
okay
so i'm going to take this one out of the
vehicle
and bring the next key into the vehicle
to program
this one's saying that this one's
already programmed in
okay so now we're gonna program the next
one in
this is the next one
[Music]
i'm gonna press yes
i took the original keys already out of
the car i already took the first one out
so now i'm going to programming the new
one this is the second one
key is already in the vehicle
press ok
ok it says it's now registered so now
this key is registered also now
press ok
so now it says wait uh 100 seconds
key program succeeded would you like to
program the next one so this one's
programmed already now so i'm going to
go get the last key which is
the aftermarket key
and uh
go from there
so the third key i'm having an issue um
registering it
so uh
just gonna exit out of it
because this key didn't go in but the
other two did go in
and that's it that's how you do all keys
lost let me get the other keys
and show you that they work
okay so i have both keys here
programmed in
unlock
a lot
mirrors fold in
good to go
you have another one
a lot
mirrors fold in and out
it's good to go
uh third key i'm just gonna have to
program in another aftermarket key
i'm just gonna have to program in
another aftermarket key and then uh
and uh to do the um
the touchscreen remote for the mdx if
you guys have any questions feel free to
ask them to like share subscribe and
comment i decided to make this video
because subscriber acts like i said
again
and uh i hope this video was helpful
peace